[Music]
well the advice I'd give and if you were
my patient I'd be a little different
because we'd have a little more time but
if I can distill it down to the essence
of what we do in a course of therapy the
person with panic I can say this from
the inside out since you're looking at a
panic disordered person in recovery has
adopted a posture with regard to the
world within in which their own anxiety
is their enemy and they think that if
they can just get the anxiety to go down
go away not occur as much or not kurwa
such an intensity or at least not occur
here or there in that situation that
then things would be better in fact all
of that is not the solution to the
problem it is the problem holding
anxiety is your own enemy and that it
has to go down diminish it go away and
that happened here is a kind of self
invalidating interior focused process
that would get you even more entangled
with these processes instead what we're
going to need to learn to do is to allow
your history to bring into the present
thoughts and feelings and memories and
to sort of hold them mindfully and so
compassionately and then focus on what
you do and bring them along for that
journey so you know feelings are only
your history being occasioned by the
present moment if that's your enemy then
your history is your enemy
if sensations are your enemy your body
is your enemy if memory is your enemy
you better have a way of controlling
your mind in such a way that you never
reminded of things that are painful from
the past well there is no such thing
like that
that's healthy and most of the things
that people do that are called
psychopathology are the unhealthy things
people do when they try to accomplish
that agenda if you avoid people avoid
having your buttons pushed avoid going
to places that might occasion anxiety if
you're hammering down drugs and alcohol
these are all methods of trying to mount
that unhealthy agenda so I would say
could we instead take this anxiety to be
something that may be of importance may
even be meaningful
and it says something about your history
and could be learned to sort of hold it
in a in a way that's more compassionate
to sort of bring the frightened part of
you close and treat it with some dignity
and keep focused instead on of making
that going go away focused instead on
what kind of life you want to live
connected to what kind of meaning and
purpose that's gonna be a quicker more
self compassion and a more certain
journey forward than this kind of out
with things I you know in with the
relaxation you know out with the
self-doubt in with the confidence kind
of let's just snap out of it kind of
harsh and and lack of a non
compassionate place that we stand with
ourselves inside things like panic
disorder